in celebration of black history month  metro and the county commission honored  southern nevada's first black police  officer it happened during today's  meeting his name is detective herman  moody he joined the force back in 1946  he was a navy veteran and at the time  there was no police academy so he taught  himself how to file reports that would  stand up in court he also read books on  nevada law and taught others how to make  good arrests  moody says he believed in the historic  west side and felt its residents deserve  good police protection so he dedicated  his career to it he retired from metro  back in 1977.  moody is regarded for helping improve  the performance of what was then the las  vegas police department and is known for  being a beacon of light and a role model  for young people of any color  we thank him for his service moody is  now 97 years young he enjoys spending  time with his five children six  grandchildren and five great  grandchildren